I think about being at The Comedy Store
right now like I think it's never been
better
yeah I mean no it's probably been better
but we're over back well it's it's you
know it's the best comics in the world
you and I are lucky enough to be at the
you know we get those spots when we want
I totally agree I feel like in 10 20
years they're gonna look back at this
era and I'm gonna be like hey I'm glad I
was a part of that yeah man
but there's just amazing things going on
right now and I just think what a
combination of who your favorite comics
I'm simply the combination of podcasting
yeah with podcasting a social media
everybody comes and then this right
what's happening at the comic store it's
just it's an amazing point in people's
ears
yeah it's precisely working you know
moving boxes we're in the working man's
ear that's who's listening I know that's
true you know everything is going on
like they're both great friends with
Chris D'Elia you know what I mean and I
just think that what Chris is doing
right now is uh it's it's pretty
incredible like like a second amazing
like you could write a book about it
like just the rise in social media it's
socially and just just just collecting a
fan base the way he is so engaged with
his fan base that it's a new way it's
almost like another lane it's a new lane
of like fame and fortune it 100% you
know what I mean it's never been easier
to make more money with less effort but
that he owns he has his career mean yeah
nobody does more with less yeah you're
welcome Chris because he's there's no
crystal here without the kid you know
I'm saying what it was a hard for you to
watch that happen no you know no Chris
was undeniable that's a great word for
you me too I mean I love that kid and
about but also when I saw Mike Carnegie
Hall I was like Carnegie Hall I I need
and I were watching him before anybody
knew him and Neil was like oh he's gonna
be and he's just undeniable yeah yeah
and and I was like and then I said to me
like I just want him to read more cuz I
want him to keep this going and I want
to explain
his expression I do these weird things
and notice he's an innocent leave him
alone [ __ ] he lives to make people
laugh that's why yeah yeah yeah and he's
undeniable I mean yeah it's like he
doesn't get I don't get um I've never
felt who that guy is doing better
that's a scarcity way of thinking and
it's also false I just uh but it's when
it's a friend of mine like that I'm just
I get so excited about it I know exactly
what you're saying I feel the same way
but they're still also is a healthy
level of like envy it put you on bushes
you yeah but that's all I noticed yeah
yeah yeah I like Santa I learned a lot
from watching Chris and Brendan and all
these young dudes who were doing social
media right no I learned I was so
resistant home so now I just don't know
exactly what you saying about being
resistant bro again I was watching Rogan
he was always a social media beast yeah
and I was like [ __ ] all this I don't
want to do well it was called
self-promotion and I felt weird about it
yeah but [ __ ] all that no because again
stuck in the old school way of like no
this is how you do it you get on TV you
do a late night show people for the
clubs who support you and then now it's
just like no there's like you know and
I've realized I've realized that you
know um as we're talking I haven't
posted in about three days so I got a
post I know you know I got my agent
calling me I had this funny talk with my
agent he calls me he's like hey man you
know I'm looking at your Instagram and
like you know you guys you know you
gotta be more like CEO you know on
fields' Instagram artists Justin no it
was a Ryan over there you know but he
says right but he's what I didn't
appreciate like healing did see so I
looked at deals and I was like um you
know it's like I I don't see what you're
talking about in terms of life so I was
watching he does that podcast with Shaab
and goddamn he's funny deal can do some
fun he was just the hosting people he's
just a weird yeah he'd makes these
Corollary yeah yeah damn he's good yeah
again another person that we're seeing
like like in this particular in this era
of the Comedy Store is great to watch
the the the rise you know the work so
hard you know he's so unique but he
works hard he very unique
yeah really hardworking guy yeah he's
very considered about everything he does
I've seen it yeah you know yeah cuz it's
like he was himself but well join the
club you gotta have yeah thank you you
gotta have a little bit of that do you
can't have you should have low
self-esteem if you're a comedy yeah
there's no way the weird work and then
we have to be able to deal with like the
know all the time so that you can love
yourself man
[Laughter]